please welcome the CEO of the Academy of
Motion Pictures Arts and Sciences
Bill Cramer
thank you hi everyone I'm Bill Kramer
CEO of the academy
and it's fantastic to see you all here
to celebrate our newest nickel fellows
it's such an honor to lead the academy
which beyond the inspiration and impact
of the Oscars we support a wide range of
talent development programs and
initiatives
these programs are designed to help
Empower and support the next generation
of filmmakers creatives from diverse
backgrounds writers directors artists
Executives technicians and more
nickel Fellowship in screenwriting is an
international competition that supports
the discovery and development of new
screenwriters and is one of the
centerpieces of our talent development
initiatives
this program was formed in 1985 when G
Nichol endowed the fellowship and this
year four individuals and one writing
team have been selected as winners of
the 2022 Academy nickel fellowships
each individual and writing team
receives funding from the academy and
mentorship from an academy member
throughout their Fellowship year
our incredible Academy members volunteer
so much of their time to support the
program reading scripts serving as
judges and providing mentorship
Academy members who serve on the nickel
Fellowship committee include chair Eric
heisner who you just saw and committee
members Susan shopmaker John Bailey
Stephen poster James Planet Stephen
ulaki Jason Michael Berman Julia
Chaseman Peter Samuelson Bobby Banks
Larry karazewski Adele Lim Zach Penn Dan
Petrie Jr Katie Silberman and Dana
Stevens we are so grateful to you all
nickel fellows have and continue to have
an impact on our industry helping to
evolve and expand film's powerful
ability to entertain educate and Empower
audiences across the globe
recently produced film projects
involving nickel fellows include Shang
Chi and the legend of the ten rings
co-written by Dustin Daniel [ __ ] and
Andrew Langham and directed by Destin
Lost Girls written by Michael where we
together together written and directed
by Nicole Beckwith and top gun Maverick
which was co-stripped scripted by 1996
nickel fellow Aaron Krueger
and this is just a few of the many
nickel success stories
so to our new class of nickel fellows I
offer my heartfelt congratulations and
on behalf of the entire Academy family
please know that we are here to support
you as your careers in filmmaking
progress
now it's my pleasure to introduce our
host for the evening who is also the
director of tonight's scene readings
Barbara stapanski
Barbara is it all right
come on out I'm Barbara is a wga award
winner a nickel fellow and an
award-winning independent film director
please join me in welcoming Barbara
[Applause]
[Music]